Transcription: Jacqueline Lemay
Relecteur: eric vautier
Est-ce que vous avez déjà eu l’expérience
de nager la nuit ?
Nous sommes le 29 mai 2021.
Je prends mon premier relais de nuit.
J’enfile ma combi toute froide,
toutes humide.
La ville est complètement endormie.
La rivière s’écoule dans un noir obscur
et seule une petite luciole
est là pour me guider.
Je sens l'eau glisser sur ma peau.
Tous mes sens sont en alerte.
Alors, j'offre ma confiance
absolue aux éléments.
Pendant cette heure de nage,
mon esprit m’amène à cette question :
« Qu’est-ce que je fais là ? »
Et c’est ce que je suis venue
vous raconter aujourd’hui.
Bonjour, je suis Chloé Léger, j’ai 25 ans,
je suis nageuse en eau libre
et l’une des co-fondatrices
de l’association Zéro Mégot.
J’ai été, depuis l’enfance,
baignée dans le sport.
Mes parents sont le genre de personne avec
qui vous ne voulez pas partir en vacances.
C'est tout sauf reposant.
Le week-end, ils m’emmenaient sur
leurs triathlons, ces grands événements,
avec plusieurs milliers d’athlètes
venus du monde entier,
pour s’affronter
sur des parcours mythiques.
J’admirais ces super-héros sportifs,
se dépassant,
et je me suis moi-même prise au même jeu.
En 2018, j’ai été sélectionnée
en même temps que mes deux parents
pour participer aux championnats
du monde de semi-Ironman.
Cela était l’aboutissement de plusieurs
années d’entraînement et j’en ai profité
pour passer 2 mois sur place à travailler
dans les townships de Cape Town.
Mais le jour de la course, cette ville
sud-africaine avait été transformée.
Je ne reconnaissais plus le paysage
paradisiaque que j’avais tant admiré.
Un envahissement éphémère qui a laissé
derrière lui une montagne de déchets.
Alors, ce jour-là, au lieu d’être
la fille la plus heureuse du monde,
j’ai commencé à sentir une distance
entre le monde du sport
et ma vision d’un avenir plus écologique.
C’est là où j’ai décidé
de lancer mes propres défis.
Un an plus tard,
je suis sur mon petit nuage.
Nous venons de réussir,
avec Mathieu et Lucas,
la traversée du détroit
de Gibraltar à la nage.
Cinq heures vingt pour 17 kilomètres,
une distance équivalente
à la moitié du périphérique de Paris.
Heureusement, il y a beaucoup
moins de bouchons.
L’objectif de cette aventure avait
été de réduire un maximum
notre empreinte carbone.
Et nous l'avons réussi avec les objectifs
que nous nous étions fixés.
Zéro déchet, zéro carbone.
Pendant ce long train de retour de Tarifa,
dans le sud de l’Espagne,
tous enthousiastes à l’idée de se relancer
dans un nouveau défi, je m’interroge.
Pouvons-nous aller plus loin,
non seulement au niveau de l’endurance,
mais aussi dans l’engagement ?
Il fallait trouver d'une part l'aventure
que nous voulons vivre et d'autre part,
le message que nous voulons faire passer,
l'un n'allant pas sans l'autre.
Alors,
comme beaucoup,
réduire mes déchets a été un
de mes premiers combats environnementaux
et je tends vers le zéro déchet
depuis plusieurs années.
Dans le train, nous sommes tombés sur
un article sur les mégots de cigarettes.
Nous avons appris que le mégot,
depuis 32 ans, est le premier déchet
que l’on retrouve dans les océans,
et que chaque minute en France,
40 000 mégots sont jetés par terre.
Le mégot, qu’on se le dise,
ce n’est pas une cause très sexy
et je me sentais loin du problème,
n’étant pas une fumeuse.
Mais de retour à Paris, je n’arrivais plus
à marcher dans la ville
sans être frustrée de voir
les centaines de mégots par terre.
Chaque mégot contient
plus de 2500 substances chimiques
et toutes vont finir dans la nature.
Le mégot, à l’époque encore peu médiatisé
comme une problématique environnementale,
allait devenir le centre de notre projet.
Aujourd’hui, je vous partage trois leviers
qui m’ont aidée à faire du sport
un acteur de la transition.
Le premier vient d'une peur.
Moi qui n’ai ni une grande notoriété,
ni une certaine expertise en écologie,
et surtout, qui suis mal à l’aise
avec la prise de parole,
comment croire en ma propre légitimité ?
Je suis passionnée de natation
et du dépassement de soi
et j’ai envie de protéger
mon terrain de jeu.
Alors pour se construire sur le sujet,
nous avons mis en place
la technique des 50 cafés,
qui consiste à rencontrer un expert,
apprendre de sa part,
puis lui demander trois de ses contacts
avec qui il nous conseille d’échanger.
Et ainsi de suite.
Cela nous a permis de recueillir
l’expertise de scientifiques,
d’acteurs de la législation
sur la taxe pollueur-payeur,
de bénévoles du monde associatif,
d’éco-aventuriers et de cigarettiers
et bien d’autres.
Grâce à cette phase, nous avons pu mesurer
l’ampleur de la problématique,
de mieux comprendre les enjeux,
mais surtout, surtout les solutions.
Il fallait parler de cette pollution
aux Français
et leur faire passer un message simple :
« Jetez vos mégots à la poubelle. »
Mais comment sensibiliser
le plus grand nombre ?
C’est là où nous nous sommes appuyés
sur le deuxième levier :
utiliser le sport
comme média de la transition.
L’aventure Zéro Mégot
avait pour but de retracer
le parcours symbolique d’un mégot.
Pour faire comprendre aux fumeurs
ce qui se passe dans les jours, les mois,
les années après un petit geste anodin.
Parce qu'un mégot jeté par terre en ville
va retracer son chemin jusqu'à la mer.
C’est là d’où nous est venue l’idée
de descendre la Seine à la nage.
Ce rêve s’est formé en janvier 2020 avec
Louise, ma cousine, Mathieu mon copain
et Lucas, son frère.
Nous avons décidé de nager
de Paris jusqu’à Deauville,
380 km, en se relayant
jour et nuit, pendant une semaine.
Après un an d’entraînement,
je donne le départ
de cette aventure inédite.
Il y a des centaines de personnes
sur les bords de Seine.
À ma droite, Madame la Maire de Paris,
à ma gauche, la Protection civile
et devant moi,
un mégot géant de 8 mètres de long
qui se fait tracter par un kayak.
C'était énorme.
Quelques minutes avant le départ,
je suis dans ma bulle.
Je ne vois même plus les caméras.
Je repense à cette année de préparation
remplie d’obstacles.
La fermeture des piscines
pendant les confinements,
la perte de notre deuxième bateau
quinze jours avant le départ,
et la recherche permanente de sponsors.
Puis, avec une aventure pareille,
impossible d’échapper à la paperasse.
Peu de gens le savent, mais à peine
48 heures avant notre départ,
nous n’avons toujours pas
les autorisations nécessaires
pour nager dans la Seine.
Ces épisodes ont mis
à rude épreuve notre mental.
Je ne peux même pas vous faire comprendre
la vague de soulagement que j’ai ressentie
au moment où j'ai plongé dans la Seine,
au pied de la tour Eiffel.
Presque 100 km de natation m’attendaient
dans les prochains jours
et pourtant, j’avais l’impression
que le plus dur était déjà derrière moi.
Grâce à cette aventure sportive,
nous avons enchaîné les interviews médias,
toujours en portant ce message simple :
« Jetez vos mégots à la poubelle ».
Une cinquantaine de médias, M6, BFM,
France Bleu, France-Inter, Europe 1
ont relayé notre appel écologique.
C’est là où je prends conscience que
l’aventure sportive est un média éphémère.
Pourtant, il y a une question
qui nous revenait sans cesse
pendant la préparation.
Comment faire participer
notre communauté à ce défi ?
C’est là où nous avons actionné
un troisième levier :
engager notre communauté.
Avec l’équipe, nous sommes venus à l’idée
non pas de faire un crowdfunding,
mais un « mégot funding ».
Est-ce que vous savez de combien est le
record du monde de collecte de mégots ?
855 000 mégots.
C’est le nombre de mégots qu’on a ramassés
le jour de notre départ,
en partenariat avec Surfrider Paris
et c’est quatre fois l’ancien record.
En seulement trois heures,
dans toute la ville,
plus de 1000 bénévoles, des enfants, des
étudiants, des familles se sont mobilisés.
C’est là où je réalise
la puissance du collectif.
Je n’étais pas seule dans mon combat.
J’aimerais vous montrer cette image,
qui représente un triste record, certes.
Nous ne célébrons pas la pollution,
mais l’engagement des citoyens.
Pour la petite histoire, les mégots
ramassés ont été recyclés,
certains dans cette planche de surf,
d’autres vont être transformés
en plaques de sensibilisation
pour la Ville de Paris.
Dans notre communauté, il y avait
les bénévoles, mais aussi les professeurs
et ils nous ont suivis tout au long de
l’aventure avec leurs élèves de primaire
grâce à notre kit pédagogique.
Nous sommes le samedi 6 juin.
Après sept jours d’efforts, sans jamais
avoir plus de trois heures de sommeil,
nous arrivons, main dans la main,
sur la plage de Deauville.
Cet après-midi, j’ai eu la chance
de croiser une petite fille nommée Sarah.
Depuis une semaine, Sarah, 10 ans,
passe ses après-midis
à ramasser les mégots sur la plage.
L’aventure l’avait fait rêver
et le message l’avait fait agir.
Alors quand Sarah nous remet
sa bouteille remplie de mégots,
j’ai lu dans ses yeux l’espoir
d’un avenir plus propre et harmonieux.
Ma lettre à demain s’adresse
à tous les sportifs,
que ce soit ceux qui se lèvent un dimanche
matin pour aller courir dans le parc
jusqu’à ceux qui nous ont ramené
une médaille de Tokyo.
Croyez en votre légitimité.
Utilisez le sport comme média
de la transition.
Engagez votre communauté.
Ces trois leviers nous ont accompagnés,
quatre jeunes, passionnés, un peu fous,
à faire du sport de demain
un sport écologique.
Alors, j’imagine que maintenant,
vous avez bien compris
pourquoi j’ai nagé dans la Seine
en pleine nuit.
J’étais là pour vivre le rêve
de la petite Chloé.
Mais surtout
pour offrir la chance à d’autres filles,
comme Sarah,
un jour de pouvoir vivre le leur.
Dans mon parcours, il y a beaucoup
de sportifs engagés qui m’ont inspirée
et j’espère aujourd’hui,
à ma petite échelle, en inspirer d’autres.
J’aimerais vous laisser
avec cette phrase :
dans le sport,
comme dans la transition écologique,
le vaccin contre le désespoir,
c’est l’action.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)